(gentle bright music)
- People think fat people
never get off the couch
and people think that fat people
sit around eating all day.
My mission is to challenge
people's assumptions
about fat people.
(gentle piano music)
I'm Mirna Valerio, and I'm a runner.
I've been running long
distance for about eight years.
I've done nine marathons
and 10 ultra-marathons
with my longest being 100K.
Traditionally, trail races
and other outdoor events
have not always been
welcoming to people like me.
I'm black, I'm a woman, and I'm fat.
When I go to a race, I
know I'm breaking the mold.
It's still very white and very male.
So I know going in that
I'm going to be different.
(soft piano music)
10 years ago I lived a very stressful life,
and so that took a huge toll on my health.
I consulted with a doctor who told me
that I needed to change my
lifestyle pretty drastically
if I wanted to see my
son grow up, so I did.
I'd had some experiences with people
always making the assumption
that whatever I was doing
it was for weight loss.
After a couple of years,
it was not a weight loss thing anymore;
it's about fitness.
Running makes me feel like
my most human self.
My first mile was pretty awful.
It was painful, it was slow.
When I'm feeling like this
is really too difficult,
I know that in the end
I'm doing it for a reason.
There's always a larger reason.
The end goal not always
only being to finish,
but the more important
thing is that I'm out there
because sometimes I come in last.
It's amazing to me how many messages I get
on a daily basis saying,
"Thank you for being you,
"thank you for living in your own space
"and taking up space, and
not being afraid to do that
"because that has allowed me to do that."
I'm gonna continue
doing it because I think
people still need to see me.
(dramatic music)
(chime dings)